Buonasera Buonasera Grazie grazie
dunque come sapete come vedete anche
dalla slide che vedete qui dietro il
tema del Ted Tex Ferrara di quest'anno è
possibile utopie io forse in
controtendenza rispetto agli altri
speaker che abbiamo sentito che
sentiremo parlerò di un'utopia Come
piano già anticipato che è possibile
forse ma dal mio punto di vista dal
punto di vista della mia azienda Bank
Station non è sicuramente auspicabile
quell'utopia è Bitcoin le criptovalute
Ma parliamo in particolare di Bitcoin la
regina la prima criptovaluta ora a che
titolo vi parlo di Bitcoin ve l'hanno
già detto io sono cofondatore di
un'azienda che fa educazione finanziaria
nei nostri contenuti di educazione
finanziaria nella nostra divulgazione
sui temi di Finanza non parliamo mai di
criptovalute di Bitcoin parliamo di cose
che secondo noi sono più importanti più
rilevanti per la gestione delle Finanze
delle persone parliamo di differenze tra
carte di debito due carte di credito
parliamo di Perché può aver senso avere
più di un conto in banca però le cripto
valute sono diventate sempre di più una
sorta di elefante nella stanza di cui ha
una certa Bisogna parlare se si parla di
finanza bisogna che si esprima
un'opinione e quindi noi piegandoci
sotto il peso di questo elefante nella
stanza abbiamo deciso di fare coming out
con la nostra opinione su i Bitcoin che
vedete scritta sulla mia maglietta per
chi fosse indietro c'è scritto pattume
Dunque proviamo a spiegarlo con un po'
più di criterio rispetto a questa
scritta ora se non avete mai sentito
parlare di Bitcoin andate benissimo
Secondo me quindi potete dormire e farvi
una pausa andare fuori farvi un gelato
fare quello che volete andate da Dio se
invece ne avete sentito parlare se siete
curiosi magari siete anche entusiasti
questo speech forse ha qualcosa per voi
forse qualcosa da comunicarvi dunque se
appunto non vi siete alzati non vi siete
andati a farvi un giro perché
malauguratamente avete sentito parlare
di Bitcoin probabilmente ne avrete
sentito parlare da un vostro amico
Probabilmente un maschio con un
cappellino addosso tra i 20 e i 40 anni
che vi avrà detto di usare Bitcoin per
investire Vi avrà detto di investire in
Bitcoin perché la moneta del futuro il
futuro la tecnologia robe
Che cosa vuol dire investire in Bitcoin
Allora vuol dire
scaricarsi un'app o andare su un sito
mettere uno username una password quel
sito è un Exchange di Bitcoin è un posto
dove le persone comprano e vendono
Bitcoin si scambiano Bitcoin tra di loro
collegate un conto in banca a quel sito
e
comprate Bitcoin quindi con quel conto
in banca comprate l'equivalente in
Bitcoin di che so 100 euro sono 0,1
qualcosa Bitcoin perché il prezzo di un
Bitcoin è ad oggi 25 più o meno 25 mila
euro Non chiedetemi perché però insomma
quindi comprate questi Bitcoin con 100
euro e la vostra app come fosse un po'
la app del vostro Home Banking vi mostra
un saldo di 0,5 Bitcoin perfetto avete
investito in Bitcoin
adesso che avete investito in Bitcoin
cosa cosa dovete sperare che succeda
guardando il saldo del vostro conto in
Bitcoin dei vostri Bitcoin
come in tante forme di investimento
dovete sperare che il valore di
quell'investimento vada su in modo che
poi possiate Come dire rivenderlo ad un
prezzo più alto dei 100 euro a cui
l'avete comprato volete che
l'investimento Renda questo è una
mozione di investimento
e questo è vero anche per tante altre
tipologie di investimento quasi tutte
nel senso pensiamo alle azioni di una
società investiamo nelle azioni in borsa
di una società come la Apple che fai gli
iPhone i telefoni
quello che stiamo Sperando quando
compriamo l'azione di una società come
la Apple è che appunto il prezzo di
quell'azione che abbiamo comprato va da
su in futuro in modo che poi tra un mese
due mesi in un anno 10 anni 20 anni
possiamo rivenderle ad un prezzo più
alto Stessa cosa che quei Bitcoin quindi
quello è questo quello che stiamo
sperando che succeda con i nostri
Bitcoin la differenza tra i Bitcoin e
l'azione di un'azienda è che nell'azione
stiamo Sperando in una cosa molto
tangibile stiamo Sperando sì che il
prezzo di quell'azione vada su
Ma questo è determinato in ultima
analisi da come va l'azienda
l'equitazione abbiamo comprato e come va
l'azienda vuol dire come Tim Cook il
capo di Apple e le persone alle sue
dipendenze stanno
producendo i telefoni sono bravi a
produrre i telefoni sono belli gli
iPhone Sì bene le azioni presumibilmente
tendenzialmente andranno su Quindi
quello che stiamo di fatto Sperando
quando compriamo l'azione di una società
è che quella società vada bene le
persone che ci lavorano lavorino bene Fa
che bello e con i Bitcoin invece che
siamo lì col saldo a vedere 0,4 Bitcoin
cosa Cos'è che stiamo sperando che
succeda perché non c'è un'azienda non
c'è nessuno che lavora
ci sono due ipotesi Partiamo dalla prima
quella un po' più lunga
Dunque Bitcoin Quando è stato inventato
parliamo del 2008 non era stato
inventato come strumento di investimento
era stato inventato come sistema di
pagamento
voleva essere sostanzialmente una moneta
digitale che non avesse bisogno di
nessun intermediario finanziario per
essere utilizzata
prendete sta frase adesso la spieghiamo
un attimo meglio dicono che tirano fuori
cose dalle tasche sia molto Ted Quindi
lo facciamo e
Ora
pensiamo alla differenza tra moneta
digitale e
con tante le due forme di moneta a cui
siamo abituati ho detto prima moneta
digitale che non richiede nessun
intermediario finanziario Cosa vuol dire
la moneta digitale che conosciamo Quindi
questa carta di debito
necessita di intermediare finanziari
quando la usiamo per fare un acquisto su
Amazon o per anche passare la carta al
bar nuovo la di fronte c'è una banca che
autorizza la transazione e che tiene
traccia di quella transazione una banca
che sa che io Luca ho speso €5 al bar
nuovo là davanti bene
quello che Bitcoin si proponeva di fare
come tecnologia nel 2008 era di creare
una forma di moneta in forma digitale
quindi che si potesse spendere dal
telefono dal computer con un pagamento
elettronico
che però avesse delle funzionalità più
simili invece quelle del buon vecchio
contante nella misura in cui io prendo
una banconota la do a un'altra persona e
non c'è nessun intermediario di mezzo io
vado al bar nuovo gli do 5 euro e non
c'è nessuno nessuna banca che deve
autorizzare quella transazione non c'è
nessuna traccia di quella transazione
nei registri contabili di una banca poi
c'è il registratore di cassa Ma vabbè
quindi questo era l'intento originario
di Bitcoin avere un sistema di pagamento
che fosse una sorta di contante digitale
con tante digitali è la frase che viene
usata proprio nel primo Paper che
presenta L'invenzione di Bitcoin molto
utile pensare a Bitcoin come
funzionalmente al contante perché te lo
possono rubare e non lo ritrovi più una
volta che l'hai dato a qualcuno quella
persona se ne può andare senza che
senza che tu possa avere nessuna rivalsa
quindi proprio come il contante a
livello funzionale tra l'altro Tutta la
tecnologia di cui sicuramente avrete
sentito parlare se avete sentito parlare
di Bitcoin blockchain mining
crittografia chiave private le cose in
cui di solito ci si va in telagare
quando si parla di Bitcoin sono in
realtà tutte cose funzionali a questo
scopo qua avere una moneta digitale
quindi che si spenda dal telefono o dal
computer che però abbia le funzionalità
del contante quindi nessun intermediario
finanziario di mezzo di cui ci si debba
affidare che tenga traccia delle
transazioni che sappia che quella
transazioni sono avvenute Ok quindi noi
però siamo ancora qua siamo col nostro
telefono col nostro saldo a sperare che
Bitcoin che abbiamo comprato Perché il
nostro amico ce l'ha detto quello col
cappellino Noi stiamo sperando che
Bitcoin vada su il prezzo vada su quindi
Dobbiamo sperare perché il prezzo vada
su che tante persone
vogliano comprare Bitcoin che tante
persone abbiano voglia di comprare
Bitcoin per farci delle cose e adesso
abbiamo un qualcosa in cui sperare No
Abbiamo capito che cosa Che cosa fa
Bitcoin Quindi noi possiamo sperare che
tante persone vogliono mettere le mani
su Bitcoin che siano disposte a
comprarlo da noi a un prezzo sempre più
alto
per usarlo poi per spenderlo come
contante digitale quindi abbiamo noi che
siamo qua con il nostro saldo qualcosa
in cui sperare Dobbiamo sperare che
Amazon inizia a accettare i pagamenti in
Bitcoin che la Coop inizia a cercare i
pagamenti in Bitcoin che i pagamenti in
Bitcoin si diffondono e la gente inizia
a spenderli per comprare dei telefoni
per comprare dei pantaloni magliette con
scritto pattume scarpe di tutto quindi
questo è quello in cui possiamo sperare
che bello c'è una cosa tangibile in cui
sperare affinché il prezzo vada su qua
Però c'è un problema c'è una
contraddizione e ve la provo a spiegare
facendomi una domanda anche questo molto
Ted
se questa banconota vi dicessero che tra
due mesi varrà come tutte le banconote
da €5 varrà il doppio varrà il triplo
verrà il quadruplo verrà 5 volte tanto
ci Avreste voglia di spenderla per
comprare dei pantaloni per comprare
delle scarpe e una maglietta con scritto
pattume No probabilmente Avreste voglia
di tenervela come Bitcoin sul sito e
aspettare che il suo prezzo vada sulla
luna e guadagnare
di qui si capisce la contraddizione una
moneta che aumenta di valore che è
quello che voi state Sperando è una
moneta che le persone non sono propense
a spendere quindi sperare che Bitcoin
aumenti di valore perché tante più
persone lo vogliono spendere è un gatto
che si morde la coda è una
contraddizione più una moneta aumenta di
valore che è quello che noi stiamo
Sperando più meno la gente è propensa a
spenderla e più è propensa a tenersela
per sé aspettando che aumenti di valore
Quindi questa cosa non va bene
e quindi noi siamo di nuovo qui
aspettare a sperare che i nostri Bitcoin
che abbiamo comprato Perché quel nostro
amico
aumentino di valore Però ancora non
sappiamo effettivamente bene in cosa
sperare perché speriamo che aumentino di
valore che più persone li vogliono ma li
vogliono per fare cosa l'opzione sistema
di pagamento contante digitale non va
bene
e qui arriva un'altra teoria che è
quella portata avanti da alcuni luminari
di Bitcoin più di recente che è quella
del cosiddetto bene rifugio Bitcoin come
bene rifugio secondo questi luminari ci
sarebbero alcune caratteristiche
tecniche della tecnologia di Bitcoin che
fanno sì che Bitcoin non sia tanto uno
strumento di pagamento di questa
banconota buttiamo la via e è uno
strumento di Risparmio lo strumento di
Risparmio Che significa che le persone
dovrebbero convertire i loro risparmi in
Bitcoin
e usarlo come una sorta di bene rifugio
una sorta di oro digitale qualcosa in
cui mettere i propri risparmi in un
momento di incertezza in un momento in
cui ci sono dubbi ci sono paure sul
futuro dei propri risparmi Qui ci sono
dubbi sull'inflazione che Erode il
valore del denaro dei degli euro dei
dollari ma non ero del valore di Bitcoin
e una moneta una forma di Risparmio una
riserva di valore che ci protegge anche
dalle fluttuazioni dei valore di altri
prodotti di Risparmio come per esempio
le azioni Questa è la nuova teoria no
Bitcoin secondo questi luminari avrebbe
alcune caratteristiche tecniche che lo
rendono una sorta di bene rifugio e
basta Questa è la sua unica unica
utilità bene quindi abbiamo un'altra
cosa in cui sperare possiamo sperare noi
che siamo ancora lì col nostro saldo
0,50 qualcosa Bitcoin possiamo sperare
che tante persone si rendano conto che
effettivamente Bitcoin nel bene rifugio
perfetto no tante persone in un momenti
di incertezza in cui sono dubbiosi sul
futuro dei loro risparmi e hanno paura
dell'inflazione hanno paura del
chiarovita per mettere al sicuro al
sicuro Scusate è un lapsus freudiano
i loro risparmi parlando di Bitcoin esce
proprio tutto permetterà al sicuro i
loro risparmi
scelgano di abbracciare questa
tecnologia relativamente nuova Questa
dovrebbe essere la cosa conservativa da
fare
insomma
il problema qui al di là di questa
ironia è che i beni rifugio tipici sono
beni a cui le persone sono abituati
quando le persone cercano dei beni
rifugio cercano cose a cui sono abituati
loro è un bene rifugio perché
ha un valore storico storicamente l'oro
è sempre stato un bene rifugio è
un'abitudine millenaria il mattone è un
bene rifugio Perché le persone hanno
bisogno di case quella roba lì non non
va via non va via Bitcoin l'abbiamo
detto nasce come sistema di pagamento è
fallimentare come sistema di pagamento
ma non l'abbiamo approfondito
e non serve nient'altro quindi quello in
cui noi stiamo Sperando quando siamo lì
col nostro saldo a sperare che Bitcoin
diventi improvvisamente per tutti un
bene rifugio che la gente smetta di
comprare oro smetta di comprare il
mattone e compri Bitcoin è non sperare
in una spontanea conversione in massa
sulla via di Damasco di una serie di
persone che per nessuna ragione
oggettiva cominceranno a lavorare a
investire in Bitcoin
Questo è un po' anche qui tenue Ecco è
poco più chiaramente di una speranza non
c'è nessuna ragione oggettiva per cui
Bitcoin dovrebbe diventare un bene
rifugio Le persone non hanno bisogno di
Bitcoin non c'è nessun valore storico
come per loro è soltanto una speranza e
si sa cosa si dice di chi vive sperando
quindi
Bitcoin non serve a niente Non serve
come sistema di pagamento è tenue
proprio al massimo volendo essere
benevoli come sistema di Risparmio come
bene rifugio Quindi se voi siete lì col
vostro amico che vi ha consigliato e vi
ha intrappolato e voi avete investito in
Bitcoin Adesso ve ne state pentendo
Purtroppo l'unica cosa un po' prosaica
che vi resta da fare è sperare che il
prezzo si alzi un altro po' e ci sia
qualche altro Gonzo che vuole comprare
Bitcoin a un prezzo più alto di quello a
cui Li avete comprati voi Nell'attesa di
un Gonzo ancora più grosso oppure se non
avete ascoltato l'amico Se invece non vi
siete fatti convincere Avete fatto bene
Avete fatto la cosa migliore che si può
fare con Bitcoin cioè fare a meno
Bitcoin è un'utopia è possibile non è
auspicabile quindi lasciamo che rimanga
un'utopia Lasciamo che rimanga un non
luogo Grazie
[Applauso]